el siguiente problema de optimización
que vamos a resolver es un problema que
me enviaron y el cual yo nunca había
visto así que estoy muy emocionado de
poderlo resolver el problema dice lo
siguiente toma usted o el cable de 100
centímetros o de 100 metros no importa y
ese cable vamos a cortarlo en dos
entonces este es mi cable y voy a cortar
los dos voy a terminar de leer el
problema de una vez
ya que tiene usted el cable cortado en
dos y utilice uno de los pedazos para
doblar y crear un triángulo equilátero y
el otro pedazo para doblarlo y crear un
cuadrado la pregunta es la siguiente
cual es el corte exacto que va a hacer
que el área de mis dos figuras
geométricas el triángulo y el cuadrado
sea máxima o mínima bien el problema
parece bastante interesante entonces
vamos a ver que tenemos hasta ahorita
tengo un cable que mide 100 metros o
centímetros o yardas realmente no
importa pero mide 100 y le voy a hacer
un corte de tal manera que me van a
quedar dos pedazos voy a llamar a la
longitud del primer pedazo
para cambiarle ahora que no sea x no
lleva a ser am ya la otra le podría
llamar yo p sin embargo cuando le voy a
llamar joven porque fíjense quién es la
longitud de este pedazo pues bien la
longitud del segundo pedazo va a ser la
longitud total de mi cable o sea 100 ya
esto le voy a quitar la longitud del
otro pedazo es decir para que utilizar
otra letra llamada p si podemos hacer
que ese problema solamente dependa de
una variable de la variable a la que
complicaron la vida pero bueno el
problema dice tomé uno de los pedazos y
doble low para crear un triángulo
equilátero y tome el otro de los pedazos
y doble lo para crear un cuadrado por lo
tanto se me ocurre que el triángulo lo
voy a hacer con el primer pedazo con el
pedazo que se llama a y al cuadrado con
el pedazo que se llama 100 - a esto lo
voy a hacer siempre sencillamente para
que no sea más difícil a la hora de
hacer las cuentas entonces con el pedazo
llamado a voy a hacer un triángulo
equilátero a lobo ya dibujar aquí bien
entonces este va a ser mi triángulo
pero que estoy formando con el pedazo a
si es equilátero pues todos sus lados
son iguales por lo tanto cada uno de
estos lados vale a entre 3 muy bien este
a entre 3 este a entre 3 este a entre 3
todos valen a entre 3 muy bien y ahora
con el otro pedazo dobles lo para hacer
un cuadrado entonces éste no realmente
éste no me gusta mejor este de aquí va a
ser mi cuadrado no pero no lo quiero
relleno yo solamente quiero que el
perímetro del cuadrado que va a ser esté
muy bien ya está cree un cuadrado y
entonces si este es un cuadrado y yo
tenía que mi pedazo valía si es menos a
pues hay que dividir 100 menos a entre 4
porque son cuatro lados es decir si es
menos a entre 4 es lo mismo que tiene
entre 4 que es 25 ya entre 4 que después
a cuartos o sea este pedazo mide 25
menos a entre 4 este de aquí 25 menos a
entre 4
después 25 en menos a entre 4 y el
último pues 25 menos a entre cuatro
ok hasta aquí vamos bien ya tengo mi
triángulo ya tengo mi cuadrado ahora qué
es lo que me pregunta el problema mi
problema dice encuentre el corte exacto
tal que el área de mi triángulo y el
área de mini cuadrado sea máxima o en su
dado caso sea mínima bien pero el corte
que voy a hacer yo a mi cable es a por
lo tanto me están pidiendo un valor de a
específico tal que el área de mi
triángulo y el área de mi cuadrado sea
máxima o mínima entonces vamos a sacar
áreas este es mi triángulo y la fórmula
para sacar área de un triángulo es base
por altura sobre dos pero no tenemos la
altura entonces para sacar la altura de
este triángulo voy a dividir este
triángulo en dos y si se dan cuenta son
triángulos de la forma 60 30 90 es decir
tienen un ángulo recto tienen un ángulo
de 60 grados y un ángulo de 30 grados no
voy a dibujar aquí para que quede más
claro este lado de aquí mide a entre 6
que es la mitad de uno de mis lados a
entre
/ 12 / 6 esté acá mide a entre 3 y por
lo tanto este otro lado si me triángulos
de la forma 60 30 y 90 va a medir raíz
de 3 entre 6 x a esto es con un teorema
de pitágoras que pueden checar con un
teorema de pitágoras o creerme todos los
triángulos que tienen la forma 60 grados
30 grados y 90 grados adentro su teorema
de pitágoras sale con una raíz de 3 si
lo analizan un poco se van a dar cuenta
que la hipotenusa vale 2 que uno de los
catetos vale 1 y por lo tanto el otro
tiene que valer raíz de 3 bien y si ya
tengo a la altura entonces quién va a
ser el área del triángulo pues va a ser
base por altura sobre 2 es decir a entre
6 que es la base entre 2 por la altura
que vale raíz de 3 entre 6 por la base
por altura sobre 2 la base valía a entre
3 sobre entonces a entre 6 por la altura
que vale raíz de 3 en 36 x
muy bien entonces esto lo puedo reducir
un poquito el área total la puedo
reducir un poco más que va a ser pues
raíz de 3 por ahora es raíz de tres a
cuadrada y seis por seis es 36
entonces vamos a escribirlo área del
triángulo es igual a raíz de tres por a
cuadrada y todo esto entre 36 raíz de 3
entre 36 por a cuadrado ok pero ya
tenemos el área del triángulo ahora hay
que sacar el área del cuadrado no nos
podemos olvidar del área del cuadrado
que tiene después lado por lado o sea 25
menos a entre 4 que multiplica a 25
menos a entre 4 es decir 25 menos entre
4 al cuadrado y esto es cuadrado del
primero 25 al cuadrado 625 menos porque
el signo de medios menos 25 por a
cuartos por 2 o sea 25 por 12 50 entre 4
vamos a ponerle aquí 50 entre 4 x
ya esto hay que sumarle el cuadrado del
segundo que es cuadrada entre 16 muy
bien ya tengo el área del cuadrado ya
tengo el área del triángulo por lo tanto
yo creo que ya puedo sacar el área total
de hecho es necesario sacar el área
total para este problema para que
podamos derivar bien recuerden que es un
problema de optimización entonces el
área total de todo lo voy a poner como
el área subíndice pues es el área al
cuadrado la cual está demorado ya esto
hay que sumarle el área del triángulo
entonces vamos a ponerlo es cuadrada
sobre 16 voy a acomodar los términos
menos 50 entre 4
ya esto hay que sumarle 625 625 y
sumarle el área del triángulo es decir
más raíz de 3 entre 36 a cuadrada
todo esto es el área total de mis dos
figuras el área del cuadrado y el área
del círculo y fíjense que solamente
depende de a por lo tanto ya tengo una
función que puede derivar igualar la
cero y encontrar los puntos críticos eso
es lo que vamos a hacer a continuación
bueno espero que realmente hasta aquí
vaya quedando todo en orden así que voy
a borrar algunas cosas porque ya no
tengo espacio para seguir con el
procedimiento voy a correr esto de aquí
y todo esto de acá que ya no me sirve
bueno y ahora sí voy a seguir con el
procedimiento no yo creo que también voy
a borrar lo de verde no me va a caber
aquí todo lo que he visto ser vistos en
la primera derivada la segunda derivada
ya sea un buen de cuentas mejor voy a
borrar o no borrar con rosa no voy a
borrar todo esto que está aquí bien
hasta acá
esta letra era y no se me olvide ponerla
y ahora sí ya que tengo esto voy a
derivar esta función entonces quién es
la primera derivada de a la primera
derivada del subíndice con respecto aa
quién va a ser pues es la derivada de la
expresión de acá abajo que es 2a entre
16 o sea que es lo mismo que a entre 8
lo voy a poner a entre 8 y después la
derivada de menos 50 entre 4 a pues es a
solamente te queda al menos 50 entre 4 a
los vencer o ponerla a menos 50 entre 4
la derivada de 625 hacia abajo porque es
una constante no hay nada que derivar ya
esto hay que sumarle la derivada de raíz
de 3 entre 36 a cuadrada que es 2 en
raíz de 336 o dicho de otra manera raíz
de 3 entre 18 a muy bien ya tengo la
primera derivada entonces para sacar los
puntos críticos hay que igualar la
primera derivada
es lo que voy a hacer en el paso
siguiente pero también voy a factorizar
la
aquí hay una área que yo trae entonces
vamos a actualizarla me va a quedar a
paréntesis 1 entre 8 más raíz de 3 entre
18 y todo esto que multiplica a menos 50
entre 4 de factor icelar esto es igual a
todo esto es igual a cero muy bien y
ahora pues vamos a despejar
primero voy a hacer la operación que hay
aquí el mínimo común entre 8 y 18 es a
pues esto es lo mismo que el mínimo
común entre 8 972 el mínimo común es 72
y ahora sí 72 entre 89 por 19 muy bien
72 entre 18 y 4 por raíz de 34 raíz de 3
entonces más 4 raíz de 3 y todo esto
está x ha igualado
cincuenta cuartos lo estoy pasando del
otro lado con signo positivo entonces
como ya no hay nada que reducir de una
vez voy a despejar a quién va a ser
bueno pues aquí voy a ponerlo bien
espero que no se confundan nada ok a es
igual a 50 entre 4 y voy a pasar del
otro lado el quebrado pero volteado es
decir voy a poner arriba el 72 y abajo
el 9 más 4 raíz de 3 y aquí podemos
simplificar un poco puedo yo reducir
este 4 con este 72 y me da 18 y ahora sí
va a ser igual a 50 por 18 50 por 18 y a
esto lo voy a dividir entre 9 4 raíz de
muy bien entonces vamos a hacer esta
operación espero hasta este punto no
haberme equivocado en nada entonces
esta operación se ve un poco difícil
entonces la voy a usar con la
calculadora lo que estamos buscando es
un número que esté entre 0 y 100 vamos a
ver si nos hemos equivocado entonces qué
voy a hacer primero voy a hacer primero
la raíz de 3 entonces raíz de 3 igual x
4 igual y a esto suma de 9 entonces es
15.92 8 15.92 8 15.92 8 bien 50 por 18
es lo mismo que 100 por 9 o sea 900
entonces lo voy a escribir acá arriba 50
por 18.900 entre 15
punto 9 28 muy bien si nos acordamos
entonces en la calculadora ponemos el
inverso multiplicativo y luego
multiplicamos a su vez por 900 y
obtenemos el número d
igual a 56.5 56.5 hasta entre 0 y 100
parece ser que estamos bien eso me da
gusto 56.5 bien me agrada esto todavía
no sabemos si este punto minimiza o
maximiza el área pero al menos sabemos
que encontramos un punto entre 0 y 100
es decir si yo corto en 56.5 centímetros
o metros lo que ustedes quieran
entonces ese corte va a ser un punto
crítico muy bien creo que vamos de gane
y con esto obtuvimos una respuesta que
es probablemente la solución pero ahora
la pregunta va a ser esta solución nos
da un valor en el área que sea máxima o
que sea mínima esa es la pregunta de
ahora y para nosotros encontrar si es
máximo o mínimo hay que fijarnos en la
concavidad bien para fijarnos en la
concavidad tenemos que hacer la segunda
derivada si ésta que estoy cuadriculado
es mi primera derivada entonces mi
segunda derivada va a ser un octavo más
raíz de 3 entre 18 en la cba y el 50
entre 4 también
no es necesario ponerlo por lo tanto un
octavo más raíz de 3 entre 18 es la
segunda derivada de la función adc con
respecto aa y si se dan cuenta este
valor es siempre positivo por lo tanto
mi concavidad es hacia arriba mi punto
es un mínimo mi punto crítico 56.5 es un
mínimo voy a intentar hacer una pequeña
gráfica para recordar que significaba
que fuera mínimo tengo una concavidad
hacia arriba recuerden que una función
es cóncava hacia arriba en un intervalo
si su segunda derivada es mayor que cero
esto quiere decir que mis pendientes de
mi recta tangente van cambiando de ser
negativas a ser positivas pasando por
una pendiente de 0 en mi punto crítico
muy bien entonces ya tengo que el valor
de a minimiza el área de esta función
pero realmente no habrá ningún valor que
haga que esta área se maximicen es decir
no hay ningún valor extremo sea igual a
cero o sea igual al total que haga que
esta función sea máxima me voy a poner
un poco extremista pero supongamos que
yo no hago ningún corte o que me cortes
todo mi cable entonces qué pasaría con
el área puede encontrar un área mayor
entonces voy a calcular el área
subíndice s el área total de las dos
figuras evaluada en cero a ver que me da
el área de ce evaluada en cero pues esto
es este valor es cero este de aquí pues
también es cero éste también es cero
entonces solamente me queda 625 y que
significa nuestro problema que valga
cero esto quiere decir que estoy
ocupando todo el cable para
solamente el cuadrado es decir que el
triángulo no lo voy a hacer no pinta
bien si ya sé que el área solamente de
hacer un cuadrado es de 625 cuando
utilizo todo el cable pues ahora me
tengo que preguntar qué va a pasar con
el área total cuando a vale 100 que
significa que valga 100 pues bueno estoy
diciendo que voy a hacer solamente el
triángulo es decir si solamente voy a
hacer el triángulo pues no voy a hacer
ningún cuadrado todo mi cable lo voy a
ocupar para hacer un triángulo por lo
tanto los términos del cuadrado van a
desaparecer y solamente me quedan los
términos del triángulo que era raíz de 3
entre 36 por a cuadrado y si sustituimos
entonces el valor de 100 me va a quedar
raíz de 3 entre 36
a 100 al cuadrado y hacer esto pues está
un poco difícil entonces lo voy a hacer
una calculadora raíz de tres y esto lo
voy a dividir entre 36 y lo voy a
multiplicar por 100 al cuadrado pero si
al cuadrado es lo mismo que 10.000 están
de acuerdo entonces por 10.000
va a ser igual a 481 bien entonces esta
área cuando solamente hacemos el
triángulos 481 que quiere decir todo
esto que cuando yo tengo el valor de
igual a 56.5 mi área combinada tanto de
un cuadrado como de un triángulo el área
de los dos es mínima
sin embargo cuando yo solamente tomo el
área del cuadrado y no pelo al triángulo
obtengo un área de 625 y cuando yo pongo
solamente un triángulo y no pero al
cuadrado solamente hago el área de un
triángulo obtengo que es 481 que quiere
decir todo esto que cuando yo empiezo a
calcular áreas con igual a cero me sale
625 y a partir de ahí va disminuyendo mi
área va disminuyendo mi área va
disminuyendo mi área total de los
combinados estoy hablando tanto del
triángulo como del cuadrado hasta llegar
al punto mínimo que 56.5 cuando ávalos
56.5 mi área combinada tanto del
triángulo como del cuadrado es mínima
como es un mínimo empieza a subir el
área otra vez a subir a subida a subir
hasta que llegamos al igual a 100 que es
481 por lo tanto ya tengo dos valores
para los cuales mi área es máxima y me
área es mínima el valor de igual a cero
hace un área máxima y el valor de igual
a 56.5 hace un área mínima este problema
me pareció francamente fascinante espero
no haberme equivocado nada y que se haya
entendido todo el procedimiento nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo